[Music]
this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice dr john deloney ramsey
personality best-selling author is my
co-host today
as we take your questions about your
life and about your money
thank you for joining us open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five five two two five
wayne is in san antonio hi wayne welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave hello john how's it going man
going well what's up how can we help
well question uh we've got a 12 year old
contracting business here in central
texas
and i'm 58 years old and due to the past
year and a half with covet
and then we had five very extremely
difficult
talent stretching projects just right in
a row
and i'm tired ready to give up the fight
my
my two problems that we're facing is
that one my business isn't sellable
uh without me and the
the second is that our son a 22 year old
wants the business but i'm just not
seeing the tools in this toolbox right
now
you know and my plan is is to
in the next four years i want to start
stepping out and we'll do
mentoring and teaching and uh guiding as
needed
and then you know eight years boy i'd
kind of like to be gone out of here
but uh like i said i'm just not seeing
the tools in the
in the toolbox for our son yet
and i'm tired so
you're you're and i understand you say
that you have eight years to develop him
in your mind yeah so he would be 30.
he would be and you'd be 66
yep and that would be it'd be a gradual
phasing
between now and then um
uh with the final handoff of the baton
at that point
okay yeah somewhere in that 66 to
70 somewhere in there okay well
we do know he has one major tool desire
he does okay and you can work a lot with
desire
as you know trying to light wet wood is
hard
yes it is what what tools do you think
he's lacking
he doesn't have the business acumen he's
22.
he is he doesn't even have hygiene
acumen at 22.
he doesn't have dating acumen he doesn't
have hairdo acumen he doesn't have a lot
of acumens he can't drive probably
right can i tell you i hear two
different problems here
i hear one you're looking at a 22 year
old
and it's hard for us to remember all of
us being 22
and the difference between 22 year old
john and 30 year old john
is is it's i mean that's those are two
completely different humans thankfully
and it sounds like you're gonna have to
mentor you're gonna be tired mentoring
and teaching your son
and you're gonna have to be letting go
i'm watching dave do this here and it's
just something to behold watching
somebody transition their business while
the car is still driving down the road
but the second thing is you mentioned
this several times
you're tired and turning the turning
looking down a decade from now and and
worrying about that
problem right this minute when you've
just gone back to back to back to back
to back on some major problems
man you're you're catastrophizing a
situation that i don't think has to be
catastrophized because
your body's cooked right now and
is there some ways you can get yourself
some peace now do to be intentional
about a break
about some rest about some rejuvenation
some redeveloping your mission
and then get back in the game and then
begin a decade-long
training of your son it's the it's the
lombardi quote fatigue makes cowards of
us all
right you sound exhausted man
it is i mean it's been a long road okay
so here's the thing
there's only one thing from your son's
perspective
that would absolutely there's two things
it would absolutely disqualify him
from this process okay and i don't think
you're saying either one of those things
but i'll just put them out there
number one he's a person lacking in
character
he's a little twerp and he's not going
to get any better he's
has no integrity he's a jerk nobody
wants to be around him
nobody wants to mess with him i don't
either that's not what you said i don't
that that's not the like
tool okay the second thing is if you
honestly believe
he does not simply have enough
intelligence to learn
and i don't think you're saying that
i think what you're whining about and
it's a fair whine by the way
is the distance between where you are
and where you got to get to and that
eight years is going to require a lot of
dead gum work
and you're tired but i think
i think he can get there i didn't hear
anything disqualifying him
because whatever tools he needs business
acumen
you can be taught in eight freaking
years
if you have business acumen you can
teach someone business that's a medical
degree
right you can teach them
okay i think you've got an identity
challenge here because i think you have
wrapped you have worked
real real hard to build a construction
company in central texas
and now you are the guy that some of the
people in your community go to for big
projects
and you've got a great identity in the
idea of trying to land that plane
where you're not a a pilot anymore
that's not that gets in your heart
right so i i think you can do it and i
know you can't i
and and i think he can do it too i
didn't hear any disqualifiers in here
yet um now i would put on the table
that you know here's some clips you need
some clarity
if you're going to engage in this
process i would put on the table and and
i've done this with the ramsey
children that work here right and even
uh my daughters
uh husband winston works here right runs
all of our real estate
um you don't get a pass because of your
name as a matter of fact you have to
bring it almost double just to be
respected
because of your name and so you know i'm
going to line up and teach you this
stuff and hand you this thing
but your part in it is you got to bring
it you got to be game on
you got to be super responsible you got
to be super sensitive
you got to be thinking about every word
that comes out of your mouth because
everybody is watching you
and to be respected you're going to have
to do 2x of everything
and he's got to say i'ma bite on that
apple i'm doing it
so like rachel's selling books at the
back table at a seminar at 14 years old
that's the speech she got
you don't get to put his kick back put
your feet up play pokemon or something
back here in the back you get your butt
up to the table
belly up and you sell books take money
and smile and tell those people you love
them that are walking up because you do
and by god you don't do that i mean
you're going to have a problem later you
got to bring it 2x that's teaching
business acumen and customer service and
and respect and i'd love you to be a dad
who recognizes the blessing that for the
next eight years you're going to have
breakfast coming
so far every morning i mean every once a
week with your son every ev
every week for the next eight years i
was in a two-hour strategy session with
my son and his top leadership team this
morning
and we got to play business together
cool it was so freaking fun
what a gift that is someday i'm going to
miss that yeah it was really fun
this is the ramsey chat
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you are the
next greatest generation because you
have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phone's a triple eight eight two
five five
two two five auto insurance companies
love to play the game where they see
just how high they can jack up your
rates
see how long before you catch on it's
kind of a game
but it's a game you lose every time and
so what i do is i
shop them and i use our endorsed local
providers
independent insurance agents to shop for
the best coverage free of charge across
a bunch of different companies
and they'll do that as many times as
they need to until they get the one
that's right for you which would include
for me i want a deal right i want a
better price
so uh text the word auto to 33 789
text auto to 33789 and get a trusted
endorsed local provider ramsey trusted
that would mean we endorse them at
ramsey they're local and they provide
you with help and that's the best of all
worlds right there
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings free samples free shipping
new promos all the time you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsey
get the best possible deal all right
today's question comes from
cindy in virginia cindy writes as a
naive widow
i fell in love with a man that took over
my finances
over the past six years i've lost my
home my car my boat and my bank account
he's from canada and i'm his fourth
victim i've been going to therapy
speaking with domestic violence groups
but i've lost the support of family and
friends
how do i get out of this mess
well there's a couple things here number
one
the way you pose this question distances
you
from what happened and so as a naive
widow i fell in love with a man that
took over my finances i would prefer you
to reframe
that and say i fell in love with the man
who robbed me
you've got to take ownership of this of
the situation you are in if you continue
to cast yourself
at sea with no boat no life raft no
ability to swim
you're never gonna be able to wrap your
head around um
walking on dry land and and um walking
towards solutions here
so i want you to take ownership you fell
in love with the guy you gave him
all of your finances and he robbed you
and you've got to grieve the fact that
you did that
you participated in this and then
somebody took something big from you
and going to therapy great going
domestically including your confidence
yeah he took every yeah he took your
ability to trust yourself he stole
everything from you right um but you did
play a role in that
and then if you have lost the support of
family and friends
then you need to be about finding new
community i'd want to know why you lost
family and friends and we
need to have that conversation in this
email explains why that's right
my guess is you play a part in that too
um if the people who love you and are
around you all of a sudden abandon you i
always want to well they came up and
said this guy's a freaking crook and you
kept playing crook
and you lost everything right and then
they said we told you not to do that
and then you got upset and you were mad
at them because they told you
and they had to create boundaries to
protect themselves right that's that's a
guess
yeah right so i want you to call your
family write them a letter tell you
i'm sorry i'm heartbroken i miss you i'd
love to repair
a relationship and then you've got to be
able to find other people because if
they've left you've still got to have
people in your life
but this whole thing in my eyes dave
starts with ownership
taking ownership of where you are what
happened and your role
in getting help healthy and healing next
there is um
it's not victim shaming no to
say that when i am a victim
that there is at least some part
that i played in that right okay there's
an old book called con man
or saint that was out it's about a guy
that went to jail
for running a pyramid scheme down in
florida and ripping all these people off
i read the book when i was like 18 years
old i was going around the motivational
movement at the time he had come out of
jail he was speaking and
trying to say he was a saint i don't
really think he was honestly
but it's an ancient i mean it's 40 years
ago but the only thing i remember from
the book
was the title and i only remember the
guy's name but he said
it's very difficult to con people
unless they are greedy hmm
because they are trying to get something
for nothing
and then you can set them up gotcha and
uh so they play a part in it when they
get conned in other words
okay and so and i liken it back to when
i lost everything
um and went bankrupt okay so what
happened was the bank got sold to
another bank
because the laws changed allowing that
and suddenly
the banker that i was working with that
i had trusted and done all of my deals
with and i had never been laid on a
payment got fired
and some guy in another city looks down
and says there's a kid 26 years old owes
us millions of dollars in
tennessee we need to limit this
relationship which is banker talk
for screw him and run him out of
business
so the mean old banks took dave out the
irs changed the laws and ronald reagan
changed the irs laws and screwed up the
s l business about that time
ronald reagan's fault that the snl
business went down
i'm a ronald reagan fan but he screwed
that business up
bad put basically put him out of
business what's the snl business
it was savings and loans okay yeah yeah
okay
and so uh that and the changes in the
depreciation schedules at that time
that reagan did to cause the economy to
recover in his mind
but he did it unilaterally and uh back
uh you know before and he screwed up
real estate values
in the instantaneously and so all of
these outside variables that i had no
control over
came crashing in on a 26 year old kid
and the banks called our notes
and that precipitated over two and a
half years just losing everything we own
very easy and i did for a while sit
around and whined
and blamed everybody else it's ronald
reagan's fault the irs's fault
it's the uh the bankers the banker's
fault and they all three did
horrendous things that affected me
negatively
but guess what it wouldn't have affected
me if i hadn't signed up for a trip
that i got to take gotcha that house of
cards i built was
vulnerable that business model i built
borrowing up to my eyeballs was
vulnerable and i i didn't know it i
didn't understand it but it doesn't
matter you don't get a pass on the law
of gravity just because you don't
understand it jump off a building it
kicks in
either way gotcha and so i i reached a
point
thou sitting in whining and a friend of
mine said what you just now said
he said you know you can whine about
this the rest of your life and you'll
just be that guy
or you can take all these lemons and
make some lemonade because guess what
you signed up for a trip you got to take
you got the crap beat out of you
but you went in the ring with people and
they beat the snot out of you you didn't
have to go in the ring
gotcha and i went my fault yeah
so i quit saying the banks put me out of
business
i started saying i signed up for a trip
i got to take
and it changed everything in my heart it
it gives you it
it's like being in the ocean and you
suddenly find yourself out and it's too
deep
and you're kicking your legs kicking
your legs you're kicking your legs and
then there's that moment when your feet
finally touch the sand
yeah and you just can go okay i'm here
right and if this woman if
if cindy from virginia was here i would
hug her and weep with her yes yes this
guy stole everything yeah yeah
this guy's a scumbag well these bankers
were scumbags that i dealt with right
and and they paid for it because i beat
on them for the last 30 years on the
radio so
you got a widow here who somebody said i
love you
and you're not it was a con man oh and
she was all in
and she went and then she gave her
checkbook to him and then she gave her
boat keys to him then she and then when
he misbehaved she didn't act out on it
she let it go
and something felt bad and her family
told her and her friends told her she
did it she kept going she kept going
so the person that she feels most
violated here
is cindy yeah right that's exactly what
i was she's looking in the mirror and
going oh i don't trust cindy because i
had to look in the mirror and i the
biggest problem i had was this arrogant
cocky young guy now suddenly had no
confidence
yeah i don't know those are uncharted
waters for most i had never been there
right
i'd never been where i didn't know all
the answers
yeah right yeah oh man
but it's so cinders the point is that's
where healing begins
exactly exactly healing begins when you
take responsibility not for the whole
thing
and not inappropriately and saying this
guy really wasn't a con man i'm just an
idiot no that's not what we're saying at
all
but you say i'm going to take ownership
of my part in this because
i did something that left me open to
this right
to some degree yeah my part in it that
i'm not a victim now there's part of it
you are a victim a big time
but there's part of you take your own
the only thing you can control is your
part that's it
and then once you take that that's where
healing starts it's powerful
take those lemonades baby make some
lemon we're with you take those lemons
make some lemonades let's say it
backwards
there you go oh well this is the ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text and
six gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70
a month by switching to pure top just go
to feartalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
stephen and tristan are with us hey guys
how are you good
how are you good better than we deserve
where do y'all live
st louis missouri oh good for you that's
fun
well welcome to nashville and all the
way here to do a debt-free scream how
much have you paid off
and forty 162 dollars good for you and
how long did that take
eight and a half years all right very
good and your range of income during
that time
between 35 to 70 000. nice job what do
y'all do for a living
um i'm a teacher and
i just got a job as a teacher also all
right couple teachers what do y'all
teach
i teach personal finance business those
things
i love i love this guy i love this guy
and i'm gonna teach marketing
all right two great i love it so both of
you in high school then huh
yes all right you're brave good for you
good for you
163 000 over eight and a half years
uh what kind of debt was 163 000 uh
about 110
000 of it was a house oh you paid off
what we sold we sold the house
okay wait wait wait so you still have a
mortgage uh we're renting right now
oh you're right enough for a down
payment all right that's good yep all
right
that's cool buy one crazy but that's
good well we sold it because we were
moving
okay all right about 30 000 of it was
her student loans uh well done
and then the rest of it was a lot of
stupid we had a car that we finished
paying off and those things so
okay cool wow good for you guys so
you've been on quite a journey here for
eight and a half years there's a lot to
this story
uh what got you started on this um well
we were entrepreneurs at the time
and a friend of mine we had an eight and
a half hour trip down to a
a friend's bachelor party and he said
hey you should listen to this dave
ramsey guy
and he stuck it in and for the trip down
and the trip back we listened to the
entire
fpu you had no idea i had no idea this
casual comment was going to turn into a
trap
yep force fed oh my gosh yep so we got
home and i
i went and told her about it we had just
bought a house a month before oh my gosh
of course no money down borrow the down
payment borrow everything for it and i
was like a month ago this
would have been good information to know
so he gets uh force-fed with a fire hose
for eight hours
and he comes in and tries to distill
that to one conversation i got a feeling
this didn't go well
you answer this come on tristan tell the
truth
tell the truth at first i was kind of
like i don't know
but because i kind of grew up with you
know you take out a car loan and you
make the payments and whatever
normal yep and then life got real crazy
okay in there so okay well and no wife
wants to hear
after he comes back from a bachelor
party honey we gotta talk
right right
nobody wants that conversation
what are we talking about this is a
serious conversation oh no oh no
yeah okay wow well very cool very cool
that's a long time to persevere through
this whole thing 20 000
a year for eight and a half years and
then eventually make the decision to
sell that house
as a part of it what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is
never give up so
even if you do bad one month or one year
jump right back on board yeah so dave
part of our story is
we are entrepreneurs and our business
failed miserably
so that's why the income was so low one
time she was working for free
for about a year and a half and then i i
took
income outside the business and then we
finally decided to throw in the towel
and we were living in florida at the
time and we moved back home to missouri
and
that's kind of we got this kick started
the heartbreak
yeah yeah that's
part of our story is your your dream
turns into a nightmare
absolutely and uh and and that puts that
that knot in your throat for the rest of
your life
i'm about to cry with you i'm a sympathy
crier but i also went through the exact
same thing so
i cried applebee's commercials so but um
but yeah the
uh uh yeah there's uh
yeah it's uh the dream turns into a
nightmare
and something about that nightmare
you've chosen to spend the rest of your
life working with high school
kids so this never happens to them again
we'll put you on that path
absolutely you know it was funny we were
it was july 18th before school started
and i was looking for a job and
a job back home called me and we he
interviewed via skype
hired me um said hey you're going to
teach personal finance and business
i was like okay that was what my degree
was in um and then
that school i actually got them to buy
your curriculum
yep so and i've been teaching here
teaching your principals ever since you
know
i had a good conversation with a parent
last year she goes you know you're
you're uh telling my kid he shouldn't
take out any car loans and that stuff
and he's coming home and telling me that
i did it wrong i said
i just want you to have the conversation
i said you can take with it how you want
i didn't tell your kid to come home and
tell you you were stupid exactly
i just said you were yeah i'll give you
a phone number to a couple of guys
that'll tell you you're stupid
wow we do it for a living oh that's
funny one of my favorite parts of this
job if not the
favorite is when i see folks who are
looking
in a pile of ash and they grab each
other's hand and they stand up and they
say no more
and they take a tiny step and a little
step in another step and then they've
got i see your beautiful kids over there
and you say if not for us but for them
and suddenly
every single thing looks different y'all
done this for the better part of a
decade
right and it's still as fresh in your
throats as it was 10 years ago right
absolutely that this is what heroes look
like
right here yeah right in front of me
it's incredible work you all have done
she told you the secret folks persevere
never incredible
even when you screw up even when you
fall off the wagon you crawl back
on and you go again never quit never
quit never quit
that's such an honor that's the hardest
that's the hardest part that's why you
are such heroes
very very well done good job and so you
brought the kiddos with you what are
their names and ages let's bring them up
into the debt-free scream
so our oldest is tinley she's 10. and
then we have riker who is
seven almost said six he got mad at me
at a birthday last month
and then we have ashton who is four and
then captain is three
all right good looking guys way to go
great
so they've been practicing their
debt-free scream yeah yeah they know
what all this means
absolutely all right they look ready to
me they look like that free screamers
professionals
very good we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's the
next stage in your story the next
chapter in your story where you
completely change
your family tree you're on the process
of doing that in so many ways
uh with the lessons you've learned the
things you've been through the pain
you've endured
it all gets redeemed it all gets
redeemed and used
for you to have a dream and i'm we're
looking at them right here life is good
well done you guys
well done also a copy of the total money
makeover and you know somebody that
needs that like you got force fed that
uh those cds
that's the worst trip yeah so dave every
year
i'm an fbla sponsored so i give all my
seniors a copy of your total
money makeover book oh wow as a
graduation president so well thank you
my goodness gracious you guys are
incredible thank you so much
wow all right stephen and tristan tinley
ryker ashton and kipton
it's 163 000 paid off in eight and a
half years making 35 to 70 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
all right guys you ready yeah three two
[Music]
[Applause]
one
[Applause]
i love it what a wonderful picture that
is so fabulous
i'm not crying you're crying dave that's
right and uh quit pinching me
and dad and uh dad's teaching
financial peace university and that's
what our financial
our foundation's in personal finance in
high school that i mean this is what
it looks like man by god this is gonna
change you know
and that's what happens that's a
complete and thorough transformation be
not conformed to this world
but be transformed by the renewing
of your minds the good news about
somebody like that is
um i don't know maybe you were listening
and you didn't think you could do it
what you might not think you can do is
eight and a half years
thirty five thousand dollars it's a long
time yeah
but i think you can and stephen and
tristan
know you can no whining boys and girls
this is grown-up stuff go get it step up
get em
get em this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
do
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at eight eight two five five
two two five teddy is with us in new
york city hi teddy how are you
[Music]
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i just found out about you and your
show a few weeks ago
and i'm hooked i've been binging a bunch
of your videos online
and my question is as a college student
how do i start investing i hear you
talking about these mutual funds that
increase
about an average of 12 percent a year so
i'd love to get into something like that
because
i want to start investing good for you
so
how old are you so i'm 22.
good for you what are you studying uh
mechanical engineering oh very good
degree
when will you graduate yeah i'll
graduate at the end of this year
and potentially maybe doing an extra
year for grad school
still having to figure that out i don't
want to have to take out
you know to spend a little more money to
go to school i just want to
you know hit them before running and to
get a job
okay excellent good for you what
advantage does uh
the masters in mechanical give you over
the bachelor's
so um to my knowledge it gives a more
specialization
to the area of mechanical engineering
that you want to go into and
obviously a little bit of a pay raise
okay and what's your specialization
you're aiming at
um i have a few i haven't narrowed that
down yet you
i think you typically figure that out in
senior year because that's when you take
like your technical electives
i'm looking into more like the thermal
sciences or potentially
mechatronics so like robotics yeah cool
so you're going to graduate in december
did i understand that right
uh no it's uh at the end of may so the
end of the academic year
oh i see so a year from now okay yeah
all right good so you have a whole year
left good
okay hmm and how much money do you have
to invest
um well i have about forty five thousand
dollars saved
and um about seven
to eight thousand of that is going to
pay for my rent
uh with utilities for this coming year
because uh
i go to a state school but it's not near
my house
so i have to rent somewhere else so i
estimate by the end of next year
i would have saved about forty three
thousand dollars
okay all right well um
twelve percent on forty thousand dollars
is five grand
okay and 5 000 bucks is nice if you send
it to me i'll take it
that's all right but it's not going to
change your life the difference in 40
in may or 45 in may is not going to
change your life would you agree with
that
yeah okay what will change your life is
you're
you're completing this education
debt-free and not being com not being
encumbered by a bunch of student loan
debts
uh and so i am saying that the best
investment teddy can make in the next 12
months
is in teddy and that's a mathematical
statement not a philosophical statement
it's also a philosophical statement i
believe in you but
uh but but the best rate of return you
will get is in a completed
without any debt without any
encumbrances without any weight around
your neck
degree in mechanical engineering
that is worth much more than you can
make on a mutual fund in
12 months you got plenty of time the
rest of your life to start investing
in your retirement and mutual funds and
i want you to sit down with somebody
outside of your school outside of your
graduate program
who works in the field you want to go
into maybe one or two or three of them
over the next year
and ask them about the graduate does
that matter is that actually going to
help you right now should you stay in
next year because if you got the money
and you got cash in hand you can pay for
it and walk out
it may not be worth it it may be one of
those things that
if the college is going to tell you it's
going to be worth it because they want
you as a student but
um the market may not demand it or the
market they may tell you yeah man stay
one more year and get this thing done
and you're going to have the cash in
hand to do that but when you transition
out you're going to think about car
you're going to think about where you're
going to move to all these little
expenses add up man
and you have you've set yourself up so
great
right yeah absolutely you've really done
a great job
so in other words i would just hoard
cash until graduation
and at that point once you've landed the
new job you bought the car you got the
new place you got to pay the utilities
you paid the deposit
you're set up in the new job life is set
up in the new job
then with what's left we can start
talking about working your baby steps
and getting you to a an emergency fund
and start saving towards a house down
payment and start investing
in good mutual funds but um you are a
better investment
than mutual funds are mathematically
because you are
have chosen to study something that has
a marketplace value
you're not getting some nuanced degree
in left-handed puppetry and then think
the society owes you a living
which is the biggest load of horse crap
that higher education ever sold
and i dave one of the things i remember
drastically underestimating was
i needed grown-up clothes right i had to
go to a grown-up job i had to have
like tucked my shirt in now i couldn't
just roll out of bed and go to college
um and so there's all those little
expenses man getting the car
getting those all the grown-up stuff man
so wait yeah i love that wait if
a month into wherever you're gonna be
working your new job
and then if you're sitting on 30 or 40
or 50 000 cash then you can go invest
that thing
the the irony is is that later on
neither one of us got
grown up close
i come to work in blue jeans and a shirt
every day
a buddy of mine a buddy of mine had a
guy sit him down and say
you need to start dressing up nicer you
need to dress for the job you want and
this guy had a suit and a tie
and my buddy todd is a bank executive he
looked at me goes
whatever job you have i don't want that
one i don't want to wear a suit and tie
every day
so yeah there's not many you do anymore
but uh but yeah you do have to uh you
have to be thoughtful about
uh dressing for success was an old book
when i was 18. by steve malloy
yeah dress for success that's part of
the program
justin's with us justin's in green bay
wisconsin hi justin how are you
i'm great thanks so much for taking my
call sure how can we help
well i'm 23 i have a bachelor's degree
in marketing and about 30 000
in savings i just recently started baby
step 4 uh and just start a new job but
they don't offer a 401k match so i'm
wondering if i should still pursue that
or look at like other opportunities and
ideas good for you very
cool yeah it's awesome you got things
going man so um
well here's the thing match is the best
because 100
rate of return before you start
investing which is what a match is
you put in a thousand bucks they match
it that's another thousand bucks that's
a 100 rate of return before you even get
started in investing
you can't really beat that so match is
best
the next best thing is tax free growth
which is a roth and so you would open a
roth ira since you don't have a match
and you can put 6000 bucks in that and
if your 401k
has a roth option which it probably does
does it i don't know actually yeah most
of them do these days
uh but most of them have a match so it
may not so you just have to ask
so if they've got a roth option then you
would pick the
four types of mutual funds inside that
and you would pick the um
take your own roth as well and you'd put
it across the four types of mutual funds
we talk about growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international that's the four categories
i personally invest in
and i've recommended that people invest
in for 25 30 years now
and you pick the longest possible track
record mutual funds that you can get a
hold of
and so with your you know with your
personal uh
ira roth ira you'd sit down with a smart
investor pro and you can pick those out
and you'll you can find stuff
easily with 10-year track records that
have outperformed the market
and then within the 401 k they may or
may not they may not have long track
records but get the best ones you can
get
with the best rates of return in each of
those categories and put it across those
four
and uh then if you run out of roth
meaning
let's say your company doesn't have a
roth 401k
and you do your roth and you still need
to do more to get to 15
of your income which you probably would
need to do more
then you would do non-roth non-matching
meaning a traditional so you do your
401k
so if your 401k does not have a roth
option you would do a roth ira to the
max
and then anything you've got to do more
than that six thousand dollars to get to
15 of your income you would do that in
your
401k across the four kinds and uh that
doesn't mean it's a horrible 401k it
just means it doesn't have a lot of
bells and whistles to it so that's a
really great place to find yourself man
yeah you're
23 years old you're getting started i
wish i'd had a half a clue that you got
yeah yeah you're going to be you're
going to be in great shape you keep
following the baby steps you'll be
calling him being one of these baby step
millionaires that we're hearing
this that puts us our the ramsey show in
the books thanks john good hour
good hour to james childs and kelly
daniel i'm dave ramsey your host and
we'll be back
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money if you've not talked
to checked out the dr john delony show
and um
been on it it's on monday wednesday and
friday on youtube anywhere you listen to
podcasts as well
his book best-selling book is called
redefining
anxiety and i'm working on a new book
now that'll come out next year we'll
tell you more about all of that
so be sure you check it out if you want
to participate in his show it's all
about relationships and mental health
and anxiety and
boundaries and crazy people in your
family and all that kind of stuff and
maybe you're the crazy person in your
family
i don't know all that kind of crazy
bosses whoa oh careful
careful so it's about boundaries too
boundary theory
it's about decorum what to do when
you're unemployed right
how do i spend your unemployment money
it's a hostile work environment pack
your office john it's a hostile work
environment that's warning you
okay so just ahead of time you need to
know these things uh you can email john
at ask
john ramsey solutions dot com for god's
sakes get on the
show because uh he needs some callers no
he has a tunnel we're good man
leave a voicemail at 844-693-3291 if you
want to talk to john but by the way you
could talk to him here
today and uh if you get through the
phone number is triple eight
eight two five two hope
is with us in midland texas hi hope how
are you
hi how are you guys doing today better
than we deserve what's up
well first off i just want to say what a
pleasure it was to see both of you at
summit this year in dallas that was very
enjoyable
thank you thank you for coming it was a
great event we had a lot of fun
it was great um my question today
actually uh
just a background my husband and i
together
started our own business 13 years ago
and um it's just
over the last four or five years it's
gone downhill
he and i have a lot of issues with
communicating
almost to the extent of not
communicating at all but
it is affecting our business a great
deal because he and i are not on the
same page as far as
strategy how to how to go about the
operation of the business and
get it going so i guess my question is
what kind of advice you might would have
a
relationship as well as just keeping our
business
afloat and moving it forward when we're
not
on the same page at all
how's your marriage uh suffering
yeah because of it is it the chicken or
the egg is
are they self-reinforcing one another i
guess as things were tough at home
they become tough in the office and they
become tougher at home and
the thing spins faster and faster um
have you guys stepped away from
everything and
gone over to dallas for a weekend just
to say hey what in the world's going on
or is this thing just started spinning
so fast and all of a sudden you look up
and it's a year or two later and you're
not talking anymore
um it just kind of spun and then and
yeah like you said
two or three years later now things are
just so totally out of control and
we were talking to him when he said
there's a problem too oh yes
okay yeah yeah this is one of those
moments that can
it can be a a really important it's
going to be an important moment either
way
but it can be something not to be feared
it can be a beautiful moment when
there's redefining rebuilding
excavation start over rebuilding moments
but it's gotta have to happen
somebody's gotta turn the lights off i
mean turn the lights on turn the music
off
take an inventory of the party you've
been having and saying hey where are we
what's going on
and um i love it when couples can look
each other in the eye and say hey we
need to do this and have this moment
this
we need to take a post-mortem on what's
happened and decide where we're going to
go
but somebody's got to just say stop for
a second yeah you guys need you guys
need a good marriage counselor in your
corner asap
to start with and just the business will
not heal until your marriage does
right we we have done marriage
counseling literally a little
about a year and a half ago um and
apparently you didn't do it well
right apparently not
why didn't it go well um
he kind of just checks out um
we've even done business coaching and
you know saying two different counselors
a business coach
literally fired us a year and a half ago
or
two years ago because he wouldn't
participate
we were in coaching for 15 months and he
just
wouldn't do his part of it he would
wouldn't schedule for our our weekly
uh sessions things like that he just
wouldn't he just checks out and
it's not doesn't even give any reason
just checks out and doesn't do it
um and it was kind of the same way in
our marriage counseling i mean he
attended
uh because we went together but he would
just kind of clam up
and and nothing really was being said
from his
his point and he did tell me he didn't
like the the counselor
uh the marriage counselor that he didn't
like him he didn't trust him or
something
and um it just didn't go anywhere and
literally since that time we just kind
of quit talking
literally so your your your relationship
uh if you stop and step out of it for a
minute it's on life support
yes um and i would say you're
you're in an emergency status and it
sounds like you've got a guy that's
that is unable to say hey i'm done with
this thing
is unable doesn't and i don't want to
blame don't have the tools or is it
coward or whatever you want to say but
he's unable to say i'm through with this
thing and he's going to slowly suffocate
it
and somebody's got to turn all the
lights on in that house
and send the kids away for a weekend and
say we've gotta we gotta take an
inventory
because what he's communicating to you
is he is finished and he doesn't have
the courage to say he's done
or he's scared of you or he doesn't want
to be in this business anymore and he
doesn't know how to say it out loud
somehow
he is um slowly pulling this thing under
water counseling we call it the one down
position but he's drowning the house
slowly
but surely and um usually the your
your role in this is to try to keep
yanking as hard as you can the other
direction
and it just creates this tension that
ends up sinking the boat anyway
so you've got to just stop stop the
music and say
are you done with this marriage i'm not
going to continue to participate
in crazy the way it exists no i'm going
to
say we're going to do something
different now do you want to work on
this
and heal it if you do that involves you
finding
a counselor that you trust that we can
sit down with
and that you're willing to open up in
front of and us to get this stuff fixed
otherwise it's just going to continue to
deteriorate this is not working
you know continuing to do the same thing
over and over again expecting a
different result
um it's insanity and you know and if
you're seeking outside
direction and you're not taking the
direction from outside that's him
there has to be a reason yeah and um
you know i can buy i i've sat down with
people that i didn't trust and i'm not
gonna open up in front of them
absolutely i'm not doing that i can buy
that as a reason
but the the answer is not nothing then
the answer is go find a different
counselor right
you'll find one you can he's
communicating to you if he won't find
another counselor
that is a that's a communication to you
that i'm done
with this or he just doesn't have the
tools to to work this through
whatever it is but yeah you got to have
somebody in your corner at least guiding
you through these tough
uh discussions that you have got to have
immediately
the business has not got a chance until
the marriage does
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Laughter]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five all right john you are
a
phd in counseling and you've done a lot
of trauma work
and you've done a lot of work with
couples over the years as well
um if you were just gonna you may know
some research off the top of your head
to answer this but you may also
have just an anecdotal feel for it um
when a spouse
for uh virtually for for no
obvious reason that's on the surface
that's in front of us
turns away repeated counseling
and stonewalls in counseling what
percentage of the time
is there a third party involved in
affair
i don't i don't have any data but that's
my first
that's that's my that's my number one
question i always ask somebody are you
seeing somebody else
are you done right have you if they're
saying i don't want to work on this or
are they or they sabotage all the
counseling
yeah by not showing up or by showing up
physically but not emotionally
um not relationally and so on they're
not engaged in the repair
right that will be one of the first
questions i asked if not the first
is are you seeing somebody else are you
through with this this interaction here
are you done with this person it's like
going to the doctor
and the doctor says let me do a checkup
on you and you just say
no i'm good and they say well here's
some medicine i'm good
like at some point you are deciding to
not be a part of the solution here and i
want to know why
but yeah but i'm trying to think of
otherwise
the only other only other why that comes
to mind is somebody has
such they grew up in a family that's so
maligned counseling
that's for losers or idiots or
psychopaths or crazies and you don't
need to go to counseling that's a shrink
that's for yeah i had shrinkers yeah
it's for losers maybe the
the sense of failure is so great or
man if i can't say the right thing to
make my wife okay i feel like
i mean that that makes me feel like a
loser right i get that
and so it could be something that shame
is so heavy
but i want to rattle that cage and i'm
gonna ask are you cheating on me
are you seeing somebody else right um
i just can't think of a reason other
than those two reasons why somebody
would it comes up i mean again i'm not
in that world but i end up in that world
too often
because the money you are in that world
the money piece ends up on the marriage
plate the marriage
piece ends up on the money plate and so
i end up and i'm
you know this guy is completely
disconnected this gal is completely
disconnected i can't get him to engage
in
anything on the money stuff and i'm like
they're not staying
right for some reason or another they're
not staying and sometimes when the
person calls and asks that question dave
we all have friends like this
my wife's crazy my wife's crazy my
wife's crazy you talk to your wife and
you go
no brother you are right and so it could
be that this is round
10 of some thing that she wants to fix
and he's like i'm not doing another one
of your schemes because you won't
participate so
you always get we always get one side on
the show but so i'm not saying that
happened with her or him necessarily
yeah yeah but but i but it just made me
wonder
during the commercial break from your
perspective because you've got a lot
more professional insight than i do on
it mine's just
an old guy hanging around with a whole
bunch of hurting people for a lot of
years and it just gives me a sense of
these things but
what do you think uh i would say north
of 50 yeah
that's my i just a wet finger in there
though i have nothing to base it on i'm
just
i just because i can't there
and it might be that they gave up on the
situation and then went
and got the affair rather than the
affair caused them to give up on the
situation i don't
i don't know which one that is but
they're gone
right they just hadn't left yet that's
right some people don't have the tools i
don't know how to
end the marriage i don't know how to
break up i don't want to be the one
that's the bad guy
so i'm just gonna slowly up is hard to
do i'm gonna yeah there you go i'm just
gonna drown this thing right slowly but
surely suffocated
um and then by the way on the way down
i'm going to make you feel crazy
okay yeah yeah so who knows but i i just
don't i'm not
again we're not saying that's the last
caller no
i just it just made me question and made
me wonder
i wanted and i wanted to ask you in
front of everybody else kenzie is in des
moines iowa hi kenzie welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave hey what's up
well my question today i'm going to try
to explain this as fast as i can
is i recently got engaged in april
um we before i met my fiance he had
purchased land um he has 40 acres
and i was renting um so i have a rental
um our question or my question
is we're trying to figure out we're
getting married next year in july
um what
we are trying to figure out do we build
a house on the 40 acres
um together do we find a trailer house
to throw out there or do we rent
the house together until um either the
land is paid off or i am out of debt
either the land i'm sorry the land is
paid off and you're out of debt what'd
you say
yeah so that he still owes money on the
land
um i am not i'm on baby step two
um and so when we get married
you should you should you should rent
until you get out of debt
okay and you should not buy a trailer
because trailers go down in value those
two things are easy
then the only question is are we going
to build on this 40 acres
after you're out of debt right that's
the only question remaining do you want
to live on the 40 acres
i kind of hear in your voice you don't
yeah
no actually i really do like where it
lives we're just trying to figure out
do we find somewhere else to live and
buy a house
or do we build why would you build
somewhere else if you want to live on
the 40 acres
i don't i don't know
acres yeah you need to be dead you need
to be debt-free other than the acreage
you you guys need to be clear of that
and you need to be married now i also
would tell you
that building a house is a large and
complicated project for
a brand new marriage to undertake it
makes
it makes a 25-year marriage have some
world-class fights
a 25-day marriage you are putting it at
risk
because i mean you can you can kill each
other over freaking curtains
okay thank you dave so you need to be
real careful
i i'm not sure i would say hey the
smartest thing you can do right if you
get married to build a house together as
a matter of fact i can say that's gonna
put an extra strain on a very young and
tender marriage
and i probably wouldn't recommend it but
not to the point i tell you not to do it
but it's just it's just you're asking
for trouble and you better be watching
for trouble because he's gonna knock on
your door while you're doing this john
yeah and by the way in a year when
you're married your debt is y'all's debt
and that acreage debt is y'all's debt
right
yes this is something y'all gonna put in
in this order in the snowball order and
you're gonna pay it off together there
yeah work your way right through the
whole thing very good
jeremy's in detroit hey jeremy welcome
to the ramsay show
well thanks a lot for taking my call
sure um so
what my wife and i have been angsting
over a car purchase for a little bit and
we kind of want to see what you think
how much money do you enter um right now
we've got uh 25k emergency fund
80k liquid investments 60k in our kids
college fund
great what are you talking about
spending on your car um i would like a
tesla model 3 performance it's a 65
000 car is that a used car
now this this would be new are you are
you have a million dollar net worth
1.8 yep okay um
and what's your household income so i
make a 196k a year
like six buy the car pretty easy huh
well you have the money you have the
money it's a small percentage of your
income you have a net worth of two
million dollars this is a sixty five
thousand dollar car
okay you're not you're not buying you're
not asking you're not buying a 250 000
lamborghini no you know maybe in another
decade or two but well not
maybe another couple of million in net
worth and you know but
but uh because you want your you want
your rolling stock anything with wheels
and motors totaled up to be less than
half your annual income and it is
yeah even with that i've got bonuses and
the other side and you obviously need to
pay cash for it because you called dave
freaking ramsey right
yes yep yeah that would come out of the
liquid and you don't buy a new car
unless you have over a million dollar
net worth and you do
ta-da you got a tesla congratulations
you don't get a lot of people
calling dave for permission to buy a
tesla and him saying go buy the car so
don't push your luck brother go buy the
tesla
quit asking questions to go buy the
tesla you know it's me it's a guideline
that's right i don't tell people to not
have a good life i tell them to get
their self in a position that they do
have a good life
let's get to tesla get the tesla i guess
james cut that it is a tesla but there's
that
but this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage
scott and diane are with us hey guys how
are you
wonderful welcome where do you guys live
in the
st louis area uh just across the river
whatever illinois yeah about 30 minutes
north
good to have you guys so welcome welcome
welcome
how much debt have you paid off a
hundred and fifty five thousand dollars
yay and how long did this take seven
years eight months
okay excellent and your range of income
during that time
75 000 to 90 with a coveted backslide
last year about 30
cut last year that's a bite yeah
ouch yes and yet we still paid off the
house
completely free complete yes how old are
you guys
i'm 49 she's i'm 52. all right
your condition i will not say that
number exactly
when we started dating i was 18 he was
15. that works
excellent you guys what's this house
worth about 225 000.
excellent wow you've been doing this
stuff for eight years
well longer than that we actually
started in 2010
and we were here in 2012 and signed the
wall that's around the corner
yeah um and paid off 36 172 dollars then
yeah and then started baby step 3b so
you were on the original debt-free wall
that was beside the old studio yes right
in the middle
right on the m we cut the drywall out
and moved it around made it a display
around
the corner from the hallway have you
found your old signature yeah yeah
that's cool
and that was 2012 2012 yeah so uh
gosh almost 10 years ago yes yeah wow
you guys this is amazing
how's it feel it's still days is not
real
you know and uh but it is so much more
freedom
and you didn't realize how heavy that
burden was
you know until you started making a plan
to
get rid of it yeah and now it's gone
have you had the first
month where there's no mortgage payment
yeah we paid it off at the end of
march so we've had a couple months of no
payments and i'm the one that usually
balances checkbook and pays the bills
and it still doesn't
it just feels weird well it doesn't feel
right like you missed something
exactly that's a lot of money on that
side of the ledger right yeah
exactly it's funny when you've been
carrying a bunch of weight for a long
time you put it down your arm feels
weird it feels like you're still
being on the boat all day and you get on
land and it's so wobbly right yeah
exactly
that's that's interesting that's
incredible you guys very well done what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is
the key is is the budget that's
absolutely we have not missed a budget
since march
2010 yes and doing the budget together
and
coming up with the the same goals and
dreams
and outlook and so those two things
working together because we were both
sort of on the same page but not totally
and so
you know even if we're both going sorry
this direction
you know even if we were like this then
it recorrected us and
and got us going both the same direction
with the same goals and
and dreams so you've been working the
baby steps all the time putting the 15
away oh yeah oh yeah so what are your
investments looking like uh
real well uh when we started this you
know back in 2010
our net worth was negative uh we are
healthy six figures probably
hopefully millionaire status in the next
three to four years yeah you should be
there yeah should be there shortly
yeah that's what i was thinking with
that house paid off and everything yeah
way to go guys
baby steps millionaires look at you how
do you keep doing this for seven
years well a couple that's a long time
a couple things as diane said we were
focused together and also we have
coordinated fpu 18 times
whoa so we have lots of accountability
partners throughout our community
you can't let all those people down no
no no no no so we probably have
600 to 700 people have gone through it
that we've got as accountability
partners
yeah that'll do it yeah that'll do it
well and then also
i mean just watching and re-watching fpu
and each time
you know there would be new things that
i'm like i don't remember him saying
that before
and so i mean we still took notes the
18th time
[Laughter]
wow so all the jokes are still funny to
me
you're so precious thank you thank you
i love you you're amazing you're my kind
of people yes
and it's still funny to me but i laugh
at everything
yes that's so great that's so great
that's fun
way to go you guys yeah we're so proud
of you thank you congratulations
we couldn't have done it without the the
pathway that you made
wow thank you and you walked it and ran
it and ran it and walked it and stumbled
and did it
yeah well done very very well done put
two kids through college during that two
years oh really yes wow yeah no student
loans oh no no
guys you got to lead with that and
that's great too that's bigger than
paying off a couple of
other houses you paid off right yeah wow
yeah that's a big deal and so now you've
launched two kids out of the world with
no student loan debt
yeah and their parents have a fully paid
for house they're not gonna have to
put you guys in a retirement home and
you've completely changed the legacy
absolutely incredible are they behaving
oh yes both of them are doing
very well yes our son's still at home he
has high functioning autism so he'll
probably stay with us for a little while
but he has had a job since he was 16
and um is saving for his retirement
saving for his first house
and our daughter's out on her own and
working for the same company that i
worked for when she was a baby
wow absolutely loves it and she's been
able to get an apartment with no credit
no credit score it can't be done it
can't be done is there anything we tell
people to do that they have not done
this is amazing she's bought a car she
bought two cars with cash
how do you do that the next generation
she's a financial peacemaker we're
screwing up a lot of people's
excuses listening all the excuses are
gone now that you're here
yeah no excuses that's so fun well done
well we've got a copy of the legacy
journey you probably have one but i'm
going to give you another one
i'll give you a copy of the total money
makeover i know you had one of those but
i'm gonna give you another one
and you can give both of them away to
somebody and pay it forward that'll be
awesome we're so proud of y'all thank
you
congratulations thanks for sharing a
great story of
just being heroes just taking control of
your life very very well done
thank you for the opportunity scott and
diane say louis every
155 000 paid off seven and eight
seven years eight months making 75 to
90.
house and everything we're looking at
weird people
count it down let's hear our daddy free
scream three
two one
[Applause]
that is how it's done that's so cool man
doesn't get any better than that you
know that this is uh
financial peace university uh 18 times
wow we're running a free trial on that
right now with ramsey plus
18 times yeah i guess during the free
trial if you just binge watch it over
and over you could probably do it 18
times during the free trial but
you probably wouldn't get much else done
during that time but uh
yeah yeah and it includes the every
dollar budgeting app which wasn't there
when they started nope
um the lessons are certainly updated and
polished and everything else since they
started
uh but if you want to jump onto ramsey
plus and get the free trial you can go
through financial peace university
uh you can be budgeting with every
dollar during the free trial there's
other classes there's community there's
coaches there
uh because uh you could be scott and
diane someday
no house payments just think about it
for a second no payments on their kids
nothing everybody went to school
debt-free nothing they did like every
baby step
man paid kids college did retirement
they're almost millionaires baby step
millionaires on the way
they're still holding hands they still
like each other i don't even know what
to do that's incredible
she did have to shake his hand loose to
make sure he did he's held on there
pretty tight
yeah yeah that's great
all right text trial and you can get a
free trial ramsey plus and go through
financial peace university right now
text trial to 33789
text trial to 33
7 89 you know it's uh
we we lay these baby steps and all the
nuances around them out and we talk
about them because it's the framework
by which we teach you to make decisions
because that's how we're going to answer
questions here as well
as far as the financial part of the
question goes anyway a relational
question there's a whole different set
of
of rules that you'll get into but the uh
are guidelines or principles that you'll
get into
but the
that's what we envision when we talk
this through is that somebody that
actually does it
yeah and if you actually do it it works
like what years ago we used to have a
money-back guarantee everybody said yeah
i have a money-back guarantee so i had a
money-back guarantee
if you go to the class and do the stuff
in the class it works
if you don't it won't did you ever give
anybody's money back
i would have but nobody asked because
they they're too ashamed they didn't go
to class
or they did it and it works every time
every time yeah you don't want your
money back if you did it didn't work
hello that's the thing that's incredible
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today lane is
with us in wilmington delaware hi lane
how are you
i'm good how are you guys doing great
what's up
um so in march i passed my occupational
therapy board so i have my master's in
occupational therapy however last year i
started a landscaping business
it's been full time so rather than
getting a therapy job
i went ahead and did the landscaping
full-time it's been a great source of
income
i have 12 000 left in debt and i'm
honestly just kind of burnt out so i was
trying to transition into my therapy job
now
so i have less landscaping jobs and i'm
kind of in a weird limbo
where i ha i accepted an outpatient
pediatric job which i'm very passionate
about but it's only one day a week and
so that's not enough
and i'm having a hard time finding
places that will take me for the other
four days
why did you leave the job you had before
you had another job
so i didn't i am a small business owner
so i
i couldn't grow anymore without hiring
someone and i didn't want to have to do
that because then you make a lesson i
don't have a problem i don't have a
problem with that i'm just saying why'd
you shut it down before you had the new
job lined up
oh so i i did not shut it down okay i'm
still doing it
but i have less jobs now than i did
so did you intentionally take fewer jobs
um yes i did because i honestly was
burned out and my attention to detail
was going down and i didn't want to
provide people services to that mindset
um and i was ready to get started with
my professional career
for what i went to school with com that
part i'm in complete alignment on it's
just the timing thing yeah
right um what did you say
it was the timing thing you dropped you
stepped off of one income
to no income i just would i would have
loved for you to have had your i mean
i'd love for you have just gotten
uh you know your your occupational
therapy job and just quit
landscaping right
it's so getting credentialed through
insurance takes like a month so actually
a month ago
i sent in some applications and then i
found out now after i already dwindled
down the job
that getting credentialed through
insurance takes some time yeah
um and i do have twelve thousand dollars
left of debt which i feel like is eating
me alive
um and i kind of feel like a bum having
even like
two days off a week um so this is kind
of just like uh
i don't know i can't go anywhere i could
go to a really great restaurant
and apply and work there and make money
but you know who knows in a month i
might have to say i have to leave
you know i don't think morally right to
do so listen listen listen
you're cooked yeah okay
and i've sat with i can't even tell how
many students who have finished their
boards or finish the bar exam or finish
whatever and they're just cooked
and so where you find yourself is you
are fried but you did jump off
um you you chose to stop paying
attention to detail because you got
tired
right it's not something that happened
to you it's something that you chose to
do
you are just zonked okay and what
happens when you get zonked to sometimes
you start catastrophizing and start
creating situations that then you try to
solve that haven't even happened yet
so what i'd love to see you do is go
find somebody in your community you can
talk to just go talk to a counselor once
or twice just go find something or go
out with your friends have people over
to your house
i want you to be human again
okay you've been a robot attacking tasks
for a long time yeah you've been in
fight or flight
for years okay you're gonna have to
take some more lawn jobs and do some
more landscaping jobs until you land a
full-time job and then here's what you
do
you call your landscape clients and say
i'm getting out of this
and so here's your two-week notice and
then you move on
right and they will find somebody else
but you have over
thought this and overspun this because
your body's cooked
and you just need to start laughing
again invite some friends over to your
house again
you gotta make some money so you're
gonna have to pick up some more jobs
again if you just can't start that
lawnmower one more time then go get a
job at a restaurant i just don't know
why you wouldn't just do it for another
five or six months
getting your boards it's fr you thought
you were gonna right into a new job as
soon as you pass that test we're gonna
start on monday
and then you realize are you freaking
kidding me there's more hurdles
yes there's more hurdles and so now
you're right back in it
take some more jobs make some more money
but start being a person
make the transition by christmas yeah
but don't make it by tuesday don't make
it by tuesday you're so close honey
you're so close and you're so strong and
you've made it you're gonna be good
but you're not quite there yet okay so
maybe
like christmas
you're tired but you're so close this is
a terrible example and i wish i had
another one off top of my head but this
is live radio
you know when you're in a long car ride
and you got to pull over because you
gotta go
and then it feels right when you get to
the gas station all of a sudden it
becomes a super emergency
right that's where you're at that's
where you feel you just gotta hang in
there
okay don't go in the car wait till you
get inside okay
[Laughter]
maybe the worst live radio analogy i
think it
probably qualifies as one of the worst
ever
hey i know you're fried i want you to
have some people over this week you'll
watch a movie you get some pizza it's a
glass of wine you all laugh
but start re-engaging humanity again
elaine you're strong enough to hang on
to do the transition wisely instead of
this
gap that you left between the incomes
which is now scaring you more
than the burnout scared you
does that make sense i i have no reason
to stress financially i just got married
in june and
you know i'm we're everything's great so
is not about math it's not about math
your stress is that your body has been
in fight or flight it's been on
cortisol and adrenaline for years and it
finally just said
enough you've been cranking through
these tasks and it's just you you've
you've been on in a a machine
in a good way but very robotic but but
uh it got you through there
and you can go you can go from here so
you got the stuff it takes
you're just gonna have to make this
transition a little more gentle uh
because it's driving me nuts yeah
genie is are more gradual i don't know
incremental jeannie's in tampa florida
hi genie how are you
hello dave john i'm will thank you very
much thank you so much for all you do
thank you how can we help um i
am 59 years old getting ready to
reinvent my life
um after 30 some odd years out of the
traditional job market and i'm trying to
decide
if it makes more sense to sell my home
and relocate to a less expensive area
for
a fresh store why are you reinventing
your life of 59 i love
your spirit in that language what what
what's going on
that's how sadly i'm facing a divorce
after 33 years of
marriage oh that's hardly a reinvention
yeah when was it final um it isn't yet
um i so i'm kind of in the process of
that um
right now turned out after coming to
financial peace in 2009 i didn't have a
financial problem we had unfortunately a
relationship problem
so i had my elt over last night and i
got a price for the house what i could
sell my home for my home
is paid for um however
after it was all paid for it ended up
getting an equity line on it so i do
actually
have two debts that would need to come
out of the home if i chose to sell it
what are you using for income after the
divorce
uh that's a bit of an issue um i
actually i belong to business boutique
and um by trade i'm a writer and so
as you well know with the publishing
market the way that it is it's been kind
of
changing so um i've been self-employed
for 30 years now and so i'm gonna have
to kind of
figure sort of figure that out so i'm
trying to get a job hasn't been working
but um you know i do have
attendant money so um how much money do
you have
will you have what will you have when
the smoke cleared
the house i'm sitting in it that's it
what's the house worth
that's it uh 225 according to the erp
lady who looks very nice
if we could get your income going so i
knew you had something to live on i
would tell you to slow down and not sell
it fast
okay unless the house holds memories and
emotions that you'd rather get away from
that's part of the problem they've quite
frankly it's kind of
my my support system is here but that
said is like all i want to do
is full run this has been going on for
quite a while now unfortunately
you want to clean you want the white
board wiped off i don't mind you selling
that i don't
you know what i do is just sell a house
and rent for six months but what i would
also do is not touch the money don't
touch it
go get some money go get a job and make
make enough money to survive without
touching the money don't use this money
to
be your fresh start go get a job
anywhere go get you a nice apartment
somewhere
get you a fresh emotional well-being
around you
but don't spend the money
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsyshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today
as we talk about your life and your
money it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five kisha is in wichita
kansas hi keisha how are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve how can john and i help
well um i don't honestly i'm not sure
that i'm asking the right question
but i i'm struggling with feeling like
if i approach my mother-in-law i
disrespect my husband
um because my mother-in-law
talks negatively about me to family and
friends when she is upset
and honestly i'm not sure why
it started shortly after we
became married we've been married almost
six years have two great children
um and it's just kind of getting worse
so i don't
i know i can't control other people but
i want to
support and respect my husband in every
which way because
um he leads a wonderful family
and so give me an example
when she gets upset give me an example
of that so the most recent was
she was in a disagreement with her other
son
and she
then called him disrespectful
and isn't sure where he learned that and
said that i must be rubbing off on him
as well
um did he immediately tell his mom
do not disrespect my wife no that was
her son her brother
that was that that was my brother-in-law
um but
he shared he shared that with my husband
and yes
my my husband immediately
talked to her and said don't ever do
this again
oh good um you know but but this is it's
not the first time and i know it's not
going to be the last time
so how is her what's her reaction when
her son what do we do
when her son calls her on the carpet
your husband and says hey mom you can't
talk about my wife like that come on
what's your problem stop it what did she
say
right there's no apologies there's
blaming
of either him or i
um she's never wrong with it
okay so there's really there's really
two choices you got um
right choice number one is let your
husband know hey i i'm feeling this
burning in my soul i want to sit down
with her and just ask
i'd love to make peace with the
grandparents of my kid
the grandmother of my kids right you'd
have to understand
and you make peace with the fact that
peace may never come
and at the end of the day you've got to
unhit yourself from this woman who's
just
choosing to bring poison into your life
and i know that sounds trite and silly
and how am i supposed to do that at the
end of the day you're gonna have to make
a decision
that old lady can just say whatever
she's gonna say but i'm gonna love my
kids i'm a good wife i'm a good friend
i'm a good neighbor
um i got a great husband and i'm gonna
go about my life i'm not gonna let her
dictate my world right
i i am a i'm personally a fan of
face-to-face conversations but i've had
to make peace over the years with the
fact that some people
a don't want to have them with me or b
they have no interest in any sort of
reconciliation because like you said
they're narcissistic
never wrong yeah they're never wrong
but i always want to know i went down
swinging on that one yeah you gave it
every shot
so it might be that that you you and
your husband and
uh your father-in-law and mother-in-law
go to dinner one night you all buy
and just say um you know i'm not trying
to correct you
at all i just want to tell you that we
love you we respect you
and i don't want anything but good
things between us
and i and i won't be ever saying
anything bad about you behind your back
ever right you can count on me to cut to
take your back
i'll always take your side behind your
back
and if if i ever have any issue with you
either your son or i will discuss it
with you we will not discuss it with
other people
and we just want you to know that we
love you and respect you and and
gosh if you could do that for us that
would be the greatest gift in the world
but even if you don't
we love you we respect you and you're
the grandparents of our kids
and it just shames like it just shames
the crud out of it it's the old bible
verse about heaping coles right yeah
if you can't have a in person you can
write a letter just tell her i'm glad
you're the grandmother of my kids i love
you
and i want you and i respect you and um
like i love
that i hope that you'll do the same for
me yeah
if you ever have any challenge with me
please give me a shout but here's the
thing
some people make a decision to be test
pilot for a broom factory
and and this woman is she she's like a
second degree lieutenant
test pilot for the broom factory that's
what she is
and so if she just decides i'm gonna be
a [ __ ]
the rest of my life and you're attached
to her through her son
you just have that attachment and you
just go that's the crazy one over there
in the corner look at her
check out the pointed hat you know i
mean so that's just you know you just
have to kind of put that in your head
and kind of grin and go on because every
family's got some right
right that's that is that is very true
it's hard but that that's where you said
it you said it early in the conversation
you said it
you said i can't control her
so i mean you you've intellectually got
that part but the problem put it down
the next trip is
to emotionally get that part and there
you go i can't control it
because here's what you're trying to do
you're trying to figure out what it is
you're doing and you're not doing it
you're not doing anything there's
something way back
in her childhood that just is in in her
interaction with her husband or
something who knows i don't know
somewhere along the line hurting people
hurt people and usually these situations
are real frustrating for me because we
got a husband
who won't step up to his mom and that's
not the case here you got a man you
gotta love
your husband i love your husband it's
awesome and he
do too yeah he's good he's
you know because usually i i get this
wife i get this call and i'm dealing
with a wuss and a husband
he won't stand up to his little mommy
right you know and
this guy's a stud and he wasn't mean to
her he just called her out
yeah but in her world anybody in her
little narcissistic world anybody who
calls her
out is called mean yeah you're just so
mean so
here's here's the messy part of this you
have a fantasy in your head
about christmas and thanksgiving that
has these perfect grandparents that
welcome your kids and they run out of
the car and they hug you
and you can call her about challenges
with your kid
this doesn't exist you're just gonna
have the halloween character show
yeah thanksgiving you gotta let the
fantasy go
and i hate that for you
but it's most families it's most famous
it is it is but i we all have the
fantasy and it's in
it's like freaking leave it to beaver
did this to this culture we all think
june cleaver's out there somewhere
and she's i don't know where she went i
think she died about a generation ago
but
but we've got the little white picket
fence and the little functional family
most families put the fun and
dysfunction i'm just saying
oh this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
still on baby step number one huh how'd
you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget
don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
if you guys had any idea how hostile
work environment this
is behind the scenes before the
commercials go off it's unbelievable
i don't know how kelly and james sleep
at night man those who are ruthless
it's uh they are ruth yeah just getting
an argument with a phd in psychology
it's
it's not healthy open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five that's true they're
both crying
triple eight eight two five five two two
five y'all jump in we'll talk
if you're struggling to keep up with
payments uh you know what it's like to
be scared i do
it's not easy and you don't have to live
like this when you pay off your debt
and you do it quickly you never have to
have that kind of stress in your life
again and you can do this here's where
you start financial peace university
millions of families have taken this
class and learned how to pay off debt
take control of their money
and you can stream all nine lessons
right now
you can get some extra support by going
through the class with others and the
only way to get financial peace
university
is through ramsey plus you can get a
free trial to the membership
of ramsey plus by texting trial to 33
789
don't be held back put an end to the
worry
into the stress financial peace
university a free trial
at ramsey plus text trial
to 33 7 89
ishmael is with us in denver colorado hi
ismail
what's up uh
yes sir um i have a
trucking company uh phoned it for about
three years and i've just been recently
listening to you guys
and learning the new ropes of
how to manage my money
i have about uh in the business
i have about 32 000 in debt
and then personally i've got
about 21 000 and uh student loans
and i just wanted to know how would be
the best way to
uh to budget for the business and then
also try to get out of my
my my hole that i've digged myself
so i'm guessing that you own the truck
and you drive the truck and that's your
trucking company
uh yes sir yes there's not other trucks
involved or other drivers involved it's
you and one truck right
hello
uh-oh he didn't like your answer dave we
just lost him no i think we just lost
him i didn't do anything offensive yet
i didn't hit him on the uh i'm just keep
lying long enough to be offensive
but um yeah i'm just i'm just getting
there yeah okay
so we'll come back to that uh see if we
can get him back up in a second
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five john is in atlanta hi john how are
you
hello good evening um dave and john
question for you
so i have i'm sorry glenn go ahead no
that's great
okay um so i have um i have
beneficiaries set on my retirement
accounts
as well as on my term life insurance
outside of work
and then my life insurance at work and
then the supplemental life insurance i
have at work as well
so i'm trying to understand like when
and why do i need a will
um in case i well we're not divesting
basically
you're single yes okay
well i think your will is going to be
very simple and very clean but i would
have one
my guess is you have a car don't you uh
yes i have a car
and mortgage and um emergency fund money
as well
okay so getting possession of that bank
account that car
title and getting that house sold is
going to be 20 times easier
with a will for whoever's left with this
job to do
than it will be without a will because
they're going to have to go into court
and get permission on every stinking
little thing in probate court
if you don't have a will so your will
says i name
so and so how old are you 30 well
probably 37 pretty soon
and you're single who would be the
executor of your estate who would be in
charge of
handling your estate
um i guess it would be one of my parents
yeah i haven't decided who yet but one
of my parents well let's just for
for purposes of discussion we'll call it
your dad okay
yeah or let's call it your mom your mom
your mom is going to be the executor of
the estate an
executor the word executor means execute
their job they're an executor they
execute
what the will says that's all they do
and so if they have a will she hires an
attorney
a few hundred dollars they go to probate
court get the will approved
and then the judge will give the
executor full powers
to sell the house sell the car sign the
title for the car
sign the title to the house clean out
the bank account and use it for the good
of the people in the will now the
executor's job is to do what you said to
do in the will you're going to say
sell everything and give the money to
whoever and that's what the wheel's
going to say but yes you definitely need
a will
okay go to mamabearlegalforms.com
they're inexpensive to do online you can
do it very quickly
very easily um they've got some
worksheets and stuff that'll help you
get just
you know you got to have an executor
appointed and then you've got to decide
who your heirs
are and the the more
prep you do before dying the easier it
is on everyone that's left behind
and so this is a gift to people that you
love
is the way you look at a will the way
you look at life insurance the way you
look at naming the beneficiaries
you're obviously a very diligent person
anyway so you're just missing this one
thing
but um john my estate plan is very
complicated because there's a
bunch of crap in it and and so making
sure that everybody knows where they
stand
what the part is what to expect uh what
not to expect
those kinds of things in our in my
estate plan is a gift of mine to the
relationships of the people that are
left behind because people fight more
over what somebody meant to do
that they didn't say out loud in a will
and didn't have documented properly than
they do anything else just about in
families
and when you're grieving you hear things
differently
you imagine things differently i know so
many folks who have already
spent money of estates that they're not
even right everything
comes to a head i love the way you say
that it's a gift just think of the
people that you love
grieving your loss and you want to
provide them with the
smoothest avenue towards cleaning this
mess up yeah right i mean the antithesis
of it is snarky
but is if if you want to leave your
family all fighting with each other
and you think that'd be fun that's like
the ultimate
existential practical joke but you want
to just leave this bunch of jerks all
being jerks to each other forever leave
a very complicated estate with mixed up
directions
and not much of a will and they will go
into hyper mode
the the statement that a buddy gave to
me one time we were just all hanging out
and they said talking about their wills
and i said i don't have one
and my buddy john said the only reason
to not have a will is if you hate your
wife and kids
yeah and i remember thinking oh oh okay
right
if you want the state of texas or the
state of tennessee or the state of
nebraska taking care of your family
don't have a will they'll do a great job
because they do a great job taking care
of everything else yeah i mean
you've been in that dmv line lately yeah
yeah they'll just still be great for
your weeping
family looking for uh groceries so yeah
man and if you're in his situation
it's a gift to your mom it's a gift to
your dad it's a gift to your loved ones
it's a gift to your nieces or nephews
whoever the beneficiaries are going to
be of your of your estate
um and it doesn't take long less of it
goes to the lawyers
less of it goes to the state less time
is consumed
executing your wishes when they are
clearly laid out
in a will and it's just an absolutely
vital thing
i will say this there is not an excuse
to be an adult
in the united states i don't have a will
period it's gotten too cheap
you can do it online you can go to a
local attorney's office it's
just too easy to do it's inexcusable to
not have it
our sponsor mama bear legal forms is
just they make it very they did mine
that's
i i wanted to see what it was like and i
got a simple will
just get it done yeah and here's the
thing wills need to be state
specific yes which means the state that
you are currently residing
those laws will apply to your estate
nothing else
so i don't care where you used to live i
don't care where you grew up i don't
care where your property is
the laws in the state you reside in when
you die will apply to your estate
and so if you have moved states your
will may be invalid
uh and if you've had a major family up
evil you've gone through a divorce or
the loss of a loved one or something you
may need to redo your will
we when we moved here we did ours right
yeah you should because you're
not in texas anymore and texas law is
considerably different than tennessee
so there you go get it done
[Music]
so
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
zachary and tracy are with us hey guys
how are you we're doing great dave how
are you all doing
blessed blessed bless life is good man
good to have you guys where do you live
we're from los angeles california
awesome and all the way to nashville to
do a screen yes sir
how much have you paid off we paid off a
hundred fifty thousand dollars
whoa and how long did this take 44
months
44 yes all right cool under four years
and your range of income during that 44
months 78
000 to 150 000 whoa double it there you
go
game on what do you guys do for a living
well i'm a manager at a worldwide media
company
and i work from home i'm a
stay-at-home dad and i run an online
company yeah i hope you're doing
voiceovers
you used to be in radio in hawaii
actually yeah yeah you got you got the
pipes for it for sure
thank you well done good for you guys
excellent what kind of debt was the 150
well a hundred thousand of that was
student loans between the two of us and
then the rest was credit card and
miscellaneous
okay so you're just kind of normal yeah
just been gathering up how long you all
been married
uh we've been married for over seven
years now but together for a total of
17.
okay so what happened 44 months ago that
broke this loose
uh back in 2016 i lost my job at a
company i was
at for 10 years i started there with 15
people
and then we grew it to about a thousand
oh plus
and it was basically bought out uh they
attempted to get rid of me
and that discouraged me uh going back
to any corporate job i was a
repossession manager for
auto title loan company oh so
i used to be the bad guy so i
it was a blessing in disguise that i was
fired and so after
that had happened i had done uber and
lyft
and amazon deliveries and
eventually that led us to starting our
own e-commerce business
and that plugged us into a lot of online
groups and communities of people who
were like us small business owners
and i noticed that every time somebody
would ask a question about personal
finance your name would pop up
and i had no idea who you were never
heard of you before finally one day i
decided to look you up online and it
happened to be during one of your live
shows
i saw a couple do their debt free scream
and after that i was
hooked i started listening to your show
regularly read the total money makeover
put together a budget
but i knew that none of that would um
happen unless we were both on the same
page so i told him about financial peace
university
and he agreed to take the class with me
and at the time we
found out that we were pregnant so we
were very excited at becoming first-time
parents and
it gave us even more motivation to want
to get out of debt but while we were
doing fpu
unfortunately that first pregnancy ended
in a miscarriage
and so that was one of the hardest
things that we went through on this
journey
because i lost all motivation i didn't
want to talk to anybody didn't want to
see anybody
and it took time to heal but we got
through it we graduated from financial
peace university and
zack was 100 on board and we both
started attacking our debt together
way to go you guys awesome you fought
through a lot
yes we did job loss and uh
miscarriage and everything wow that's a
lot to fight through a lot of adversity
yeah
44 months you kept going and kept going
it can go scratch your way through all
that you're gonna make it
yeah that's pretty cool all right cool
and you brought uh your little daughter
with you what's her name a rainbow baby
bella gloriana all right yes bella for
beautiful
right yes all right uh she's ready to
see it is beautiful
she's ready to see mom
i love it way to go what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
um well because we're a married couple
definitely being on the same page
none of this would have happened if we
didn't share the same goals and the same
dreams of
wanting to change your family tree and
to build a better future for a family
and
for me it's budgeting i do i run analyze
online e-commerce so it's a lot of
purchasing
selling what not and communication has
brought us
closer together even though we were you
were married for seven years i mean
and together for 17 we never talked
about money until
just a few years ago and another key for
us is um
giving generously before we would only
give like a dollar
here a couple dollars there because we
were scared that we weren't going to
have enough money but
when we started the baby steps we
started tithing regularly to our church
and that became
the top line of our budget and every
time an opportunity came up for us to
give
cool then we would and we we realized
that
by being generous and giving and putting
kindness out into the world god has
blessed us in so many ways oh yeah
so we're very grateful for all of that
that's fun
way to go what's the name of your church
um saint charles bromeo catholic church
in north hollywood
cool and where did you go to financial
peace university um shepherd of the hill
in
um porter ranch yeah yeah very good you
guys
well i'm proud of you thank you you're
your biggest cheerleaders
uh i have a friend that i speak with
daily
uh he he runs the e-commerce business as
well his name is jeff
hey jeff and um we actually we
we kept to ourselves mostly because we
knew that a lot of our friends and
family
wouldn't understand what we were going
through you know we're all conditioned
to believe that debt is normal
that student loan debt is good debt and
that it's necessary to have
a good credit score and we hope that our
friends and family that are seeing this
today
will realize all the sacrifices that we
made and why we had to say no to them so
many times and
that they realized um that they were
sorry and that they realize that no debt
is good debt and that
um real wealth true wealth doesn't come
from a high credit score
hey man where'd it go you guys i'm
excited for you
dude yeah just watching you too
love that little baby girl it's so cool
and she's not going to experience any of
this stuff she'll go through her life's
hardships but she's not going to have
this
road blocking farmers congratulations
guys thank you
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure is that changed
legacy way to go and a copy of the total
money makeover and you can
of course give that to somebody and pay
it forward and get things moving
so proud of you guys welcome thank you
zachary
tracy and bella beautiful bella
los angeles 150 000 paid off
in 44 months making 78 to 150 count it
down
let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one
[Applause]
cool man that's fabulous i think little
bella was a little scared
i don't know i think she's heard her
parents yell like that before it's all
good
that's so cool man that's so fun what a
great celebration
very very very well done open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two five griffin on twitter says
john how do i find a balance between
being a workaholic
and being on dave's program during and
after fpu
it's so hard hmm i think you've
like you've got to have a mission you
got to have a destination and a deadline
and you got to do the math and you got
to work really hard that's gazelle
intensity right
and working a lot of hours does not mean
you're a workaholic no
that means you're in a season that's a
hyperbola bunch of drama that's exactly
what that is the definition of a
workaholic is
someone who's an addict to work who's
trying to achieve for their self-esteem
right and it goes on for years and years
and years
yeah and this is not someone who's
trying to earn their way
trying to that's right someone working
to hit a goal
in a healthy manner and putting in a
whole ton of hours for a short period of
time
living like no one else so later they
can live like no one else working like
no one else so later than work like no
one else
is not by definition a workaholic that's
what somebody calls their friend when
they used to hang out
and now all of a sudden they're working
really hard so they can get out of debt
and you say
you're just a workaholic workaholic he's
we should talk to him yeah
no he's got a goal in mind he's laser
focused on something
well i mean uh i think the word is just
misused
yeah a lot and sometimes it's done
facetiously and sometimes it's just
people have a bad definition of it my
wife has said in the past she goes you
know
back during those times you were kind of
a workaholic and i really wasn't
i've never in my life drawn well i'd say
maybe in my early 20s i did
but other than that i have not drawn my
self-esteem
from my work or my accomplishments see i
have i've had seasons where i was
on call 24 7 and then joined the police
force and then was working and then
you're not working for a goal then
you're working trying to fill an empty
hole that's exactly right and that whole
no matter how much money you make how
much you can't throw anything you cannot
fill it you cannot fill it up that's
right
that's all that's working that's a
workaholic that's a holic
something you know it's something aholic
that's right when you're throwing stuff
in that hole that's what you're doing
but just simply working hard while
you're in financial peace university
working three jobs and a crush out of
that so that you never have to again
that is not the definition of workaholic
call the champion go get it brother
yeah that's it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today romans 1 16 for i am
not ashamed of the gospel because it
because
it is the power of god that brings
salvation
to everyone who believes general george
patton said
better to fight for something than live
for nothing
ishmael is with us in denver we got him
back
talking about his trucking company if i
remember you so ishmael i was asking you
before we lost you
you have one truck and you drive it or
you have a whole staff or what
uh no sir i drive it
basically dispatch my own loads yeah
your trucking company is you
and a rig yes sir okay that's why i
wanted to make sure i understood what i
was talking about okay
so the budget for your
business is you're already doing one
we're just gonna formalize it and make
it more accurate
because you're forgetting some things
you already do one in your head
because that's why you take a uh you
know you're you're
you're dispatching your own loads so you
take a load
and you know it's going to cost you x
number of dollars in fuel and
some maintenance to get that load to its
destination right
yep and you take that load and you know
about
how many loads you're probably going to
get in a month because how long you've
been doing this
for a little bit for a little over three
years
okay all right so you know pretty
clearly then
you know in a given month typically in a
in august you're going to make uh you're
going to make so many loads and your
gross revenue is going to be
x you probably could tell me pretty
close to what august is going to look
like if i asked right
yeah bare minimum i'd say like uh about
um 20 000 maybe yeah
top top line before expenses and you
might that's the bare minimum so
but more than likely you think you'll
make how much
really what's your real uh not not
not way over but not way under
yeah i would say about twenty five
thousand that's what i would like
yeah okay good and if you made twenty
five
000 you could probably tell me what your
expenses would be
fuel for one would be fairly easy to
calculate right
yeah my fuel runs about like 1500 a week
and then and then if you do 25
000 worth of loads you're gonna have
fuel of six thousand bucks is that all
uh close to that i would say
um well it's a little bit more some yeah
lately it's been
right on the rise okay so what we're
doing is we're doing august budget
you're following me
correct i got 25 000 at the top i'm
gonna spend i think seven
thousand four hundred dollars on fuel
because it's on the rise and we're gonna
do four weeks worth of
1500 plus a little bit on the rise and
we're got a pretty good month going here
25 it's not a bare bones month
um and then what kind of repairs would
you have in your typical month
uh i'd say about
um anywhere from like
15 to 2000 maybe all right let's call it
2 000 we got 7
000 in fuel that's nine what are we
gonna run our uh our food cost out while
you're on the road you see what i'm
doing here i'm just laying it all out i
want you to just put this on a piece of
paper
you can do it with a blank yellow pad if
you want
yeah okay that's a budget that's a
budget you're predicting your revenues
and you're predicting your expenses
thereby you're predicting your profits
before the month begins and when it
comes to your debts that you have
you're going to put them in order
smallest to largest
and you're going to begin knocking them
out one by one by one
yep exactly in that order and there's
not a business debt because you signed
personally for it so it's all your debt
you got 32 000 on the business but you
signed that personally and you got 21
000 on personal but you signed that
personally
so you know you've got uh what 53 000
worth of debt you got to clear here and
you can do that
because you're probably making yeah
you're probably making close to 100 a
year
profit aren't you um get close to about
uh last year i think we were about 75
yeah we were after expenses
that sounds low but uh but you go back
and run it again i mean you got your
actual taxable income you could look at
your tax return and tell that
but yeah so if you got 75 and are you
sleeping in the rig
uh no no sometimes i'm over the road but
most of the time it's
mostly local so uh my rent's about
680. okay so now we're starting to run
your personal budget
what you're going to do with your 75 or
your 85 and then how much of that we're
going to be able to apply to this 53 000
in debt so i'm going to predict that
you're going to be out of debt in under
two years
okay and if you get an ice chest and go
to a grocery store and
make your lunches and your breakfast you
can get out even faster
yeah because this is i mean 25 000 a
year for two years
out of 75 would be 50.
okay and that'd be you'd be debt free in
two years and i think you can do it
faster than that
because i really you ain't anything to
do but work and get out of debt that's
right
that's all you got to do for the next 18
months i think you can get there but you
just need to get real business-like
about your uh trucking budget
which creates your profit and then get
real
business-like on that profit and what
we're going to do with it you need to
set 25
of it aside for taxes when you figure
out what your profit is
because you're supposed to be paying
quarterly estimates on your profits
and if you don't you're going to get a
problem
so uh that that's the process and uh
you know you just gotta get out stay up
with your taxes and then you
you know pay your rent pay your light
bill by pay your food bill and get out
of debt
and this is what we're gonna do and it's
all gonna be just written down
ahead of time on paper on purpose
before the month begins dave do you
recommend somebody pull
out depreciation on something like that
nope
okay no what i would do is i would set
aside
repair money okay on a truck if you
don't spend it
because you may not you may not have an
expense on a
repair this month but you will within
some period of time so just say
on average if we drive that many miles
in a truck you're going to have
x number of dollars in a year of repairs
tires and breaks divided by 12. okay
and i'd be setting that aside monthly so
that when that repair comes up
you've already put the money aside for
it in a sense in an all in a truck
repair envelope in a sense
okay so you're you're setting that aside
all the time
because typically you're not going to
have an even
repair budget month to month to month to
month even on your personal car you
don't yeah
so uh yeah that's a good way to do it
all right pragati is with us in
jacksonville florida did i say that
right pragati
uh it's pregnancy how are you doing i
knew i was gonna mess it up i'm great
i'm sorry i messed up your name how can
i help
uh so yeah i'm a college student um
i've been working doing an engineering
internship since january
so i have some safe money and i'm going
back to school in three weeks
so i owe about ten thousand dollars but
i'll probably won't need it until
i graduate which is in december of 22.
i was wondering if i should invest it
should i split it up
and invest 50 percent and put some in
savings
or what should i do with it i'd leave it
all in savings and not touch a dime of
it and pay cash for everything do you
get out of school this is your insurance
policy that you graduate
and graduate with no debt
okay because the chances of a tire
blowing of you getting a job interview
but you got to fly yourself there on a
week's notice or
these expenses are going to pop up in
your last year keep that money in
account don't spend it
and you will be set up to win we're
spending it on
you and you completing this education
and you transitioning into the new job
that is a better investment than an
investment
i see do you suggest i still have about
6 000
in my savings account do you suggest
um should i put maybe 30 to 40 percent
of that 10
000 into high yield savings for a little
bit
um high yield savings is an oxymoron
there is no high yield savings high
yield savings is
one and a quarter instead of 0.75 and
you lock your money up
it doesn't matter yeah you're not going
to make enough on it to matter
i mean if if you made twenty percent on
ten thousand dollars is two thousand
dollars that does not change your life
what changes your life is you completing
your education and you going and getting
the new job
that's worth a lot of money and then in
a year if you get there and you've got
the car you've got the clothes that you
need for this new job you're ready to
rock and roll and you still have 16 000
in the bank then you get into investing
yep good for you though
way to go great so proud of you very
very well done john goodaur john dr john
deloney check him out on the dr john
delony show our
very popular podcast from ramsey
networks uh james charles is our
producer kelly daniel is our associate
producer and phone screener i'm dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
is james childs a producer of the ramsay
show you can listen to all our shows
with the ramsay network app on your
smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you